that was very nice thank you for that
standing ovation uh
what did you say it it does sort of look
like they're happy i'm leaving that's
that
yeah that's what it looks like to me
it's like almost gone yeah you know what
i mean all right
that's your problem you should talk to
your therapist about it yeah yeah yeah
my therapist said you should have gone
our time is up my therapist stands and
applauds when i leave
yes you do toby uh-huh
we know all right nice though
where's you know we're writing things
down here our last show on tbs is
next thursday june 24th and uh
yeah yeah five shows left before we wrap
up the nightly format and then i'm off
to learn my children's names
the boy is ben i uh
all you've ever called him around me is
boy and girl boy and girl yeah yeah
good enough uh still feels weird to be
around so many people you know i've
noticed
that some people actually lost weight
during the pandemic
yeah it's true yeah yeah we call those
people [ __ ]
it works who does that
just do i'm gonna miss doing the nightly
show uh but our plan is to eventually
re-emerge on hbo max at some point in
some new form
and uh and i got news for you
this is exciting i'm told we have this
is exciting and hbo max
executive here tonight who wants to say
a few words
i think this is cool because i might
learn something too let's bring them out
let's find out what's going on
thank you so much i'll assume that
applause is for hbo max and why not
hi everyone and hi conan i'm hal brian
o'neal and i just wanted to come out
here
and express to you how really excited we
are about the possibility of you joining
the hbo max family
thank you thank you very much that's
nice i have to tell you for a long time
i have felt that hbo was
the uh standard standard of excellence
in uh television programming i really
feel that way well you've got that right
and with your zany sense of humor
and stellar people skills you will be at
diamond level in no time
i'm confused what do you mean diamond
level oh oh well once you're all signed
up with a show you start at the bronze
level right
and then silver and then gold and then
the platinum level
the only shows that make it to the
platinum level enjoy a
fruit basket all right how about those
pears mayor of east town those were
pretty good right you earned them
yum yum yum yum yum um
i'm eating a pear uh a juicy rice all
right all right
i'm sorry i'm so confused right now what
do you mean how do you get to a platinum
level what is that
well here i'll just explain to you
exactly how it works you get a show
conan by giving us your credit card
and letting us hold ten thousand dollars
for incidentals wait a minute
my assumption was i would get a show on
hbo max and you guys would pay me oh
that's a popular misconception but uh
tv has changed and hbo max is leading
the way
so i guess by making me pay you to make
a show is that right
yes well why should we invest in you if
you won't invest in you
so it's sort of like i have to spend
money to make money yes exactly you've
got it and in fact i have a little
visual aid here that will make all of
this
perfectly clear then just let me remove
this
there we go see
[Laughter]
the way it works conan is that once we
process your payment
you just need to bring in four other
shows
and then each of those shows will bring
in four shows
and then each of those shows will bring
in four shows and if you bring in enough
shows conan all together you get to keep
your show
that's how entourage lasted as long as
it did
with no conflict
this just looks like a pyramid scheme no
i don't see that at all
i'd say it's more of an upside-down ice
cream it's an actual
pyramid oh well conan let me ask you a
question
what's better than show business
i guess nothing wrong door-to-door
selling
and for every new show that you bring in
you'll start earning double max
points that you can use toward exciting
hbo max premium products
like for instance these beautiful
earrings take a look at those
gorgeous all right yeah
i know tony you can give these to your
wife yeah i don't think my wife would
wear those
well as long as someone in your family
does you'll be fulfilling your contract
doesn't matter who
the more i hear about this the less i'm
sure that hbo max is the place for me
well conor why don't you stop by our
offices we will change your mind quick
we have free massages yes that's right
we have a permanent free lance masseur
roaming the halls who goes by the name
of stop it
[Laughter]
i know i don't think so i don't think
i'm going to do it oh
one of the best things about hbo max is
that in a couple of months
they will brand you with this super cool
symbol right above your pubic mound do
you know where the pubic mound is right
now where the pupil
is yeah you know what i don't want to
see your pupil what it is is it's an
h crossed with a b and then the o forms
my initials that's fantastic that's how
it works
how brian o'neil thank you very much
let's hear it for uh for my money i
think uh best sketch player alive andy
daly
never ever ever seen this guy be
anything less than hilarious you're a
remarkable person thank you for doing
that
what i know is that you really called me
out here because i forgot to take the
props
[Applause]
remarkable remarkable man